وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على السيطره
ساقواتها بشكل كامل على مدينه سوليدار
شرقيه اوكرانيا وقالت الوزاره ان الخطوه
ستسمح بعزل القوات الاوكرانيه في بخموت
وقطع الامدادات عنها ووصفتها بانها خطوه
حاسمه في العمليات العسكريه الجاريه في
اوكرانيا كما اشادت القوات المسلحه
الروسيه بما وصفته بشجاعه قوات مجموعه
فاجنر خلال المعاركين بسوليدار
تسمح بقطع امدادات القوات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه
الاوكرانيه في المدينه
والصاروخيه الروسيه المستمره على مواقع
القوات الاوكرانيه خلال عمليه تحرير
المدينه دمرت القوه الروسيه ثلاث طائرات
حربيه اوكرانيه ومروحيه وقضت خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه في منطقه على نحو سبع مئه
عسكري